Although many MCU characters show up more
than once, not every hero and villain gets
a comeback — despite what the actors
involved might want. But that doesn't
stop them from dreaming. These are the actors
who desperately want to return to the MCU.
The second season of Netflix's Daredevil
introduced one of the vigilante hero's
greatest supporting characters: Elektra, played by
Elodie Yung. She next appeared in The Defenders,
serving as an antagonist to Daredevil
and his reluctant teammates Luke Cage,
Iron Fist, and Jessica Jones. While Elektra's
latter appearance ended in her apparent demise,
anyone familiar with the character will know
that death rarely puts an end to her adventures.
At the Wizard World Virtual Experiences
2020's Marvel Actors Panel, Yung expressed
enthusiasm at the prospect of
reprising her role. She said:
"Let me tell you, I love this
character because she's so
complex and broken [...] She's got a lot of
villain in her [...] and also a lot of good."
Yung also shared how much
she liked working without
knowing where her character arc would end up.
"Marvel [Television], in my experience,
are very secretive. So from the moment
you start auditioning until the end of a
series, you never know where it's going."
Sadly, Yung couldn't say for
certain whether Daredevil's
former flame would formally
debut in the MCU anytime soon.
Before the deal between Sony and Marvel
made it possible for Spider-Man to become
Iron Man's protege, there was Harley Keener.
Keener was the promising young inventor who
helped Tony Stark get through his struggles
with trauma during the events of Iron Man 3.
"I'm cold."
"I can tell. You know how I can
tell? Because we're connected"
However, it took six years for the character
to make another appearance in the MCU — and
a rather unexpected one, at that. He showed
up at Tony's funeral in Avengers: Endgame,
surprising many audiences who didn't
immediately recognize the teenaged Keener.
In an interview with IGN, Simpkins mentioned how
thrilled he was at the prospect
of reprising his role. He said:
"When they gave me the call that I was going to do
it, I was freaking out and screaming in the car."
Simpkins also explained that, at the time, his
return wasn't set in stone yet, so he refrained
from telling anyone about it for fear of things
going sideways. Of course, Tony Stark's heroic
sacrifice left a huge hole in the MCU — one that
Simpkins is more than willing to fill. When asked
about the possibility of Keener donning one of
Tony's suits and continuing Iron Man's legacy,
Simpkins exclaimed that he was 100% on board.
Interestingly, the time-traveling Young Avenger
Iron Lad was also mentioned as an option; one
that Simpkins said he would do "without a doubt."
You'd be forgiven for thinking that
Sterling K. Brown's participation in
the MCU was a one-and-done deal. After all,
his role in Black Panther was a brief one,
regardless of its significance to the plot.
Brown played the role of Prince N'Jobu,
the father of Erik Killmonger and uncle
of T'Challa. In his desire to extend aid
to marginalized people outside of the African
nation of Wakanda, N'Jobu works with Ulysses
Klaue to smuggle out its most precious resource,
the unique metal called vibranium. N'Jobu is
then killed after making an attempt on Zuri's
life. As such, barring any further flashback
sequences in future Black Panther movies, it
seems unlikely that N'Jobu will ever return.
However, Brown isn't averse to the idea
of reprising his role in the MCU. When
fans asked about the chances of him
showing up in a future Marvel movie,
the actor tweeted that he's open
to returning as N'Jobu, saying:
"If there's a way, I would
be honored #WakandaForever."
In the MCU, Josh Brolin lent his acting skills
and imposing frame to the intergalactic tyrant,
Thanos. By bringing the character
to life across multiple films,
Brolin cemented his place in MCU history as
one of its most significant players. However,
Brolin played another fan favorite
Marvel character outside the MCU:
the time-traveling mutant called Cable in
Deadpool 2. Since it's a 20th Century Fox
film, Deadpool 2 initially existed outside the
boundaries of Marvel's mainstream MCU continuity.
Thanks to Disney's acquisition of Fox and the
MCU's ongoing exploration of the multiverse,
however, it now appears that pretty much anything
can happen. And if comics creator Rob Liefeld is
to be believed, Brolin would be delighted to get
another shot at portraying the mutant gunslinger.
ComicBook.com quoted Liefeld as saying that
Brolin was "itching to be Cable again," saying:
"He told me he understands how
beloved his role as Thanos is,
but he doesn't look completely like Josh Brolin."
Meanwhile, Brolin himself has revealed
in interviews that Cable's appearance in
Deadpool 2 was only supposed to be the start of
the character's journey. Brolin told Ace Universe:
"I don't know what Marvel has in store, but it
turned out to be one really fun movie for me."
The MCU's version of the Red Guardian turned
out to be significantly different from his
mainstream comic book counterpart. But
David Harbour, who brought the character
to life in 2021's Black Widow, didn't seem
to mind. In fact, as he later told Insider,
he considers the role to be "one
of the biggest gigs" of his life.
And he's certainly willing to reprise it, should
Marvel ask him to come back. Harbour simply said:
"I'm down for more."
Harbour even suggested two ideas for
Red Guardian's next on-screen adventure.
In one scenario, audiences could get a glimpse
of Russia's own supersoldier through a number of
scenes depicting the Red Guardian in his prime.
Harbour's other idea for Red Guardian's return
features him going down the same road Yelena
did at the end of the film. Harbour said:
"When he finds out that [Natasha]
was on that cliff with Hawkeye and
maybe the version of the story he hears is
that Hawkeye pushed her off or something,
it's a moment when Red Guardian turns back to
the guy he was. He now wants vengeance for her."
One of the most shocking twists in Black Widow
involved an alternative take on a classic Marvel
villain. Whereas the Taskmaster from the comics
is a highly skilled ex-S.H.I.E.L.D. operative
named Tony Masters, the MCU version
of the acrobatic antagonist is Antonia
Dreykov — the mind-controlled daughter of
the Red Room's overseer, General Dreykov.
The conclusion of the 2021 film saw Dreykov
being set free from her father's grip after
spending years as his mind-controlled assassin.
With this new development for the character,
Olga Kurylenko believes that there's more than
enough story potential to earn Taskmaster a
spot on the MCU's roster of recurring
stars. In an interview with Slashfilm,
Kurylenko shared a few ideas about where
the character could go next. She said:
"It's always a danger to keep away from being
possessed and concentrate on keeping her freedom.
But it doesn't mean that she'll succeed at it. And
there's always bad forces that will
try to capture her, I would imagine."
Kurylenko added that she'd be more
than happy to reprise her role,
as she believes that Taskmaster is
"too valuable and too skillful [for
Marvel Studios] to let go." She expressed the
same sentiment in an Esquire interview too,
but clarified that it's up to Marvel to decide
if she is to get another chance in the spotlight.
In past interviews, Crossbones actor Frank Grillo
hasn't been shy about speaking his mind
regarding Marvel's handling of his character
in MCU films. During a 2021 appearance on the
Lights Camera Barstool podcast, for instance,
Grillo shared why he was initially hesitant to
reprise his role in Avengers: Endgame, saying:
"I was a little pissed off about it, 'cos
I signed a seven picture deal with them,
and it was like 'oh, you're gonna be part of the
Marvel universe, right?' And it didn't happen."
However, Grillo has been equally candid about
how much he'd like to play Brock Rumlow again,
whether on the silver screen or on a Disney+
show. In an interview with Forbes, he said:
"I would love to do [a Crossbones series]
just because I have never seen a character
be on the screen so little and yet have
such a fan following. [...] I have a
great relationship with Marvel and the guys there,
but why didn't they [...] pursue that? Why
isn't Crossbones somewhere in the mix?"
Grillo returned to voice Crossbones for
the Disney+ series What If...? — but
by his own admission, he'd be just as
eager to suit up himself. As he said:
"Oh yeah. I often say 'When Marvel
calls, I pick up the phone.'"
The connection between the Netflix Marvel shows
and the MCU has always been tenuous at best,
with Netflix's series only occasionally
referencing certain events from the films
and the MCU movies completely ignoring the
TV shows. Still, that hasn't stopped Marvel
fans from hoping that the likes of Daredevil and
Jessica Jones could somehow be folded into the MCU
canon — mainly because of the masterful
way in which those characters were handled.
For example, Vincent D'Onofrio's performance
as the iconic villain Kingpin made fans so
happy that calls for him to reprise his role
in the MCU never seem to end. Based on an
interview with Screen Rant, the actor himself
is just as keen on the prospect of returning.
After being asked about his rumored return
in the upcoming Hawkeye series on Disney+,
D'Onofrio said that he "so badly" wants to
breathe life into Fisk's character again,
should Marvel Studios ever grant him
another opportunity. He continued:
"I just have to wait for Marvel to ask
me. I think it's very clear that I would,
and the fans know that I would jump at the
chance to play again. I just need to be asked."
Marvel Studios and Kevin Feige have been
characteristically tight-lipped about the
status of the Netflix Marvel shows. Whenever the
question of reviving Netflix's hit shows crops up,
Feige's answers tend to be much like the one
he gave in a Deadline interview, when he said:
"I've been at Marvel long enough
to never say never about anything."
That said, if it were up to Jessica Jones star
Krysten Ritter, her character at least would
be making her MCU debut, as she has claimed
that she'd "absolutely just die" to play the
tough-as-nails private eye in an unquestionably
canonical Marvel Studios production.
In an interview with Screen Rant, Ritter
claimed that Jessica Jones really struck a
chord with female audiences, particularly
those who had survived abuse. She said:
"Not only because it was [...] a
great role and she's such a bad-ass,
but that character has really resonated with
people in a way that I don't know who else has."
Ritter added that she would jump at the
chance to step into Jessica's shoes again,
should Marvel call on her
to do so. Luckily for her,
rumors have since surfaced that Ritter might
show up as Jones on the Disney+ She-Hulk
series — so fans might just see the ill-mannered
investigator return sometime in the near future.
Judging from the number of times
Daredevil star Charlie Cox has been
asked if he will reprise his Netflix role in
Spider-Man: No Way Home, it's probably fair
to say that fans are hungry to see Hell's
Kitchen's greatest hero make his return.
While the actor has been decidedly careful
about the way in which he responds to that
particular question, Cox hasn't ruled
out any future appearances in the MCU.
In fact, he has even suggested a
number of ways in which Daredevil
can integrate himself into the
MCU's version of New York City.
In an interview with ComicBook.com,
Cox expressed gratitude at being
able to portray Matt Murdock and
his alter-ego for three seasons
of the eponymous Netflix show. Moreover,
as a self-admitted fan of the MCU,
Cox offered up some of his own ideas as
to how his character can return. He said:
"As a fan of the Marvel movies, I've
loved the little stuff where they pop
up here and there [...] I love the idea
of Jessica [Jones] and Matt showing up
in the background or Matt as a lawyer advising
Peter Parker. That'd be really, really cool."
Of course, given Spider-Man's imminent
legal troubles in No Way Home,
it's clear enough that he's going
to need all the help he can get...
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.